[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit hanna zimmermann und christian
sievers
hallo und guten abend wenn die angaben
aus russland stimmen dann hat die
ukraine heute erstmals einen luftangriff
auf russischem staatsgebiet ausgeführt
zwei ukrainische militärhubschrauber
sollen ein öllager 40 kilometer hinter
der grenze beschossen haben sagt der
gouverneur des gebiets das ukrainische
verteidigungsministerium sagt die
angaben seien nicht korrekt die
verteidiger melden heute erfolge der
krieg läuft aber mit unverminderter
härte weiter und das rote kreuz sagt um
den horror für die menschen in der
hafenstadt mario pohl zu beschreiben
gehen uns die worte aus christian kirsch
berichtet
überschreitet der krieg die grenzen der
ukraine fünf wochen nach ausbruch der
kämpfe diese bilder ein brennendes
öllager nahe der stadt belgorod nördlich
archiv auf russisches staatsgebiet nach
russischen angaben sollen zwei
ukrainische hubschrauber die anlage in
brand geschossen haben die ukraine
widerspricht die vorwürfe russlands
entsprechen nicht der wahrheit im umfeld
der hauptstadt kiew ziehen sich die
russischen truppen weiter zurück den
vorrückenden ukrainern bietet sich ein
trümmerfeld wirklich ein rückzug
präsidentiellen ski im don was in mario
pohl in der gegend um haghof sammelten
sich truppen für gewaltige angriffe wir
werden uns verteidigen
zwischen den trümmern und zerschossenen
fahrzeugen immer wieder tote 29
siedlungen so der ukrainische
generalstab heute habe man zurückerobert
mariupol eine trümmerlandschaft russland
verkündete heute eine feuerpause in der
geschundenen stadt zivilisten sollen
mariupol verlassen nur wie
wohin fragt sie können wir denn gehen
wir haben angst können sie sich
vorstellen zwischen toten zu leben und
zu gehen das internationale rote kreuz
plante heute versorgungsgüter in die
stadt zu bringen
und einige busse in denen menschen in
sicherheit gebracht werden sollten am
abend hieß es der versuch sei
gescheitert
viele versuchen es weiter auf eigene
faust kinder steht auf dem schild sie
haben es geschafft mit dem eigenen auto
raus aus mario pohl
wir hatten glück sie wurden nicht
beschlossen aber die beiden konvois vor
uns mussten umkehren weil sie unter
feuer gerieten
hier in kiew schützen sie ein denkmal
mit sandsäcken auch mehr als 50
kulturstätten sagt die unesco seien
inzwischen zerstört kirchen museen an
einen wirklichen rückzug der russischen
armee glauben sie hier in der hauptstadt
nicht
ich glaube es ist nur ein versuch putins
sein gesicht zu wahren vor der
russischen bevölkerung denn offenbar ist
sein plan vom blitzkrieg nicht
erfolgreich
hier vorerst verschont angespannte ruhe
atempause mitten im krieg
[Musik]
ganz entscheidend dafür wie es
weitergeht mit dem krieg in der ukraine
und entscheidend dafür wie es weitergeht
zwischen russland und dem rest der welt
ist die rolle die china spielt die
weltwirtschaft ordnet sich gerade neu
und die führung in peking will dabei
eine hauptrolle spielen am liebsten die
hauptrolle und hält sich deshalb erst
mal nach allen seiten offen dem nachbarn
russland hat china gerade eine zitat
freundschaft ohne grenzen zugesagt und
richtung putin bislang kein kritisches
wort verloren umgekehrt will china enger
mit europa zusammenarbeiten um noch ein
zitat den frieden bald zurückkehren zu
lassen das ist die offizielle
chinesische bilanz des eu-china video
gipfels heute welche strategie die
mächtigen in peking genau fahren ist
dabei genauso unklar wie die frage wie
soll sich die eu verhalten aus brüssel
anne gellinek
eu-china-gipfel und die begrüßung sagt
schon viel bloß kein lächeln kein zurück
winken die zeiten sind nicht danach der
chinesische präsident hu jintao hat nur
eine knappe stunde zeit ansonsten müssen
die eu-spitzen mit dem premierminister
vorlieb nehmen die botschaft an beide
ist die gleiche china soll seine
unterstützung für putins krieg in der
ukraine aufgeben der minimalkonsens
klingt so
die eu und china sind sich einig dass
dieser krieg die globale sicherheit und
die weltwirtschaft gefährdet diese
unsicherheit ist weder in china noch in
europas interesse
china spielt ein doppeltes spiel bislang
hat die eu keine beweise dass es
wirklich waffen an russland liefert oder
die westlichen sanktionen unterläuft
aber dass es politisch fest an russland
seite steht wird auch heute wieder klar
die usa haben als täter und anstifter
der ukraine krise die nato dazu gebracht
sich in fünf wellen nach osten zu
erweitern und russland schritt für
schritt an die wand zu drücken
wir haben auch sehr klar gemacht dass
china wenn es schon unsere sanktionen
nicht unterstützt sie wenigstens nicht
stören sollte kein europäischer bürger
würde verstehen wenn china durch seine
haltung diesem russischen krieg
verlängern würde
die europäer versuchen es mit einer art
beschwörung es müsse doch in chinas
interesse sein weltwirtschaft und
lieferketten am laufen zu halten und die
beidseitigen wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu
stärken europa ist chinas größter
handelspartner noch vor den usa so gehen
immerhin 15 prozent aller chinesischen
exporte in länder der eu aber nur 1,5
prozent von chinas waren nach russland
von sanktionen gegen china will in
brüssel bislang niemand reden dafür ist
das china geschäft zu wichtig eine
offene militärische unterstützung
russlands aber wäre eine rote linie für
europa da hat man dann schon der
chinesischen seite auch signalisiert
dass man maßnahmen ergreifen würde diese
würden aber keinesfalls zu umfangreich
ausfallen wie gegen russland denn das
ein ganz anderes wirtschafts- verhältnis
die wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen sind
von ganz anderer natur da würde europa
selber große probleme bekommen unterm
strich bleibt das china zumindest
während des gesprächs mit der eu seine
pro russische rhetorik nicht wiederholt
hat eingelenkt aber hatte jean ping
genauso wenig eine gemeinsame
abschlusserklärung war erst gar nicht
geplant es gibt wohl im moment zu wenig
gemeinsamkeiten die es aufzuschreiben
lohnte
partner wettbewerber oder rivale und
irgendwie alles gleichzeitig so scheint
china aus europas sicht gucken wir auf
die sicht aus peking mit unserer man in
peking wohl voller guten abend hat sich
den peking festgelegt was europa für
china sein soll
ich glaube für peking ist europa vor
allem eins ein ganz ganz wichtiger
absatzmarkt von hohen nationalen
interesse man muss ja verstehen dass das
chinesische modell also das angebot der
regierung an seine bevölkerung hier in
china ganz einfach ist es heißt wir
organisieren euch einen wirtschaftlichen
aufstieg und dafür haltet ihr den mund
und folgt der kommunistischen partei und
um diesen wirtschaftlichen aufstieg hier
in peking zu organisieren braucht man
eben euro europa als absatzmarkt ist wie
gesagt sehr wichtig verschiedener
stabilität und dann gibt es noch einen
politischen grund europa ist auch eine
begehrte braut im bündnis verhältnis man
weiß ja dass das westliche bündnis mit
amerika zur zeit durch den krieg sehr
starkes zwischen europa amerika und
chinas langfristige politik ist
eigentlich europa von amerika zu
distanzieren shipping will anteile
dieses bündnis treiben dann dann der das
westliche bündnis schwach oder
geschwächt und das ist im sinne von
peking ist nur noch anzunehmen dass
china irgendwann wegen des krieges von
russlands seite weicht
also ich glaube dass dieses verhältnis
zwischen putin und präsident sie nun
wirklich kein sehr romantisches
verhältnis ist sondern ein verhältnis
ist das komplett interessengesteuert ist
also wenn der russische präsident in
massive schwierigkeiten gerät im ukraine
konflikt wenn er probleme zu hause
bekommt dann glaube ich auch würde man
ihn hier in peking fallen lassen weil
shipping will nicht mit verlierern auf
der weltbühne stehen aber band verstehen
es geht eigentlich weniger um putin als
person sondern dafür es geht darum was
putin steht für wasser steht nämlich für
ein system ein diktatorisches das
bereitet dem westen und vor allem den
pfosten amerikanern die stirn zu bieten
und darin kann ski shipping sich
wirklich wieder finden denn genau das
will auch hier in der region machen
amerika die stirn bieten insofern geht
es eigentlich bei diesem ukraine krieg
um ein großes duell der beiden blöcke
der bald neuen blöcke auf der einen
seite amerika europa und auf der anderen
seite russland und china und deswegen
glaube ich am ende des tages wird sie
chipping immer für diesen block
entscheiden und er wird immer diktator
bleiben interessante analyse auch heute
abend wieder ulf herzlichen dank dafür
nach peking
nicht nur china hat bislang weder
sanktionen verhängt noch russland sonst
irgendwie verurteilt auch indien fährt
dieselbe linie und damit während es
bereits die beiden bevölkerungsreichsten
länder der welt in china war russlands
außenminister gerade dreimal dürfen sie
raten wo er heute ist richtig in delhi
bei indiens premierminister der den
handel mit russland ausbauen will und
oft günstiges russisches öl schielt da
kann der gast aus moskau liefern normen
odenthal mit mehr
willkommen zu sein oft kann russlands
außenminister lavrov dieses gefühl
derzeit nicht haben heute schon indien
empfängt ihn herzlich so hat sich der
russe das vorgestellt
unsere kollegen aus dem westen versuchen
jedes außenpolitische thema auf die
krise in der ukraine zu reduzieren
unsere position ist ja bekannt wir
verheimlichen nichts und wir wissen zu
schätzen dass indien die gesamtlage mit
allen fakten betrachtet und dabei nicht
parteiisch ist
unser treffen findet heute in einer
schwierigen internationalen lage statt
sie wissen dass indien immer bemüht ist
meinungsverschiedenheiten und streit mit
dialog und diplomatie zu begegnen
klingt unparteiisch aber ist es dass
indien jedenfalls nutzt die gunst der
stunde bietet sich als williger abnehmer
russischer rohstoffe an was andere
verschmähen ist gerade günstig zu haben
und indien kauft mehr denn je
indien ist natürlich an billigem öl und
gas interessiert die preise sind zuletzt
ja stark gestiegen jeder mensch tut das
doch wenn preise steigen jeder
vergleicht an und kauft in dem
supermarkt wo brot oder reis günstig ist
so macht indien das auch dem westen
gefällt das natürlich nicht er übt druck
auf in den aus aber indien kann das
sicher aushalten
das ist keine einzelmeinung in indien
delhis offizielle linie findet breite
unterstützung dass sich enthalten bei
sanktionen der uno das nicht verurteilen
der russischen invasion
in der weltpolitik geht es immer ums
überleben realistisch betrachtet muss
sich indien um seine interessen kümmern
und da gibt es nichts zu rechtfertigen
indien sollte russland ganz offen
unterstützen
wir können doch nur gewinnen wir können
öl direkt aus russland kaufen zu guten
preisen das sind starke
handelsbeziehungen auch bei
rüstungsgütern
gerade bei rüstungsgütern raketensysteme
kampfjets waffen aller art mehr als die
hälfte des indischen militär geräts soll
aus russischer produktion stammen indien
werde beliefert was immer es bestelle
sattler wolf heute abgewickelt würden
die geschäfte direkt zwischen rupie und
rubel
der grund warum wir auf unseren
nationalen währungen setzen ist die
unzuverlässigkeit des westens wir wollen
nicht von einem zahlungssystem abhängig
sein dass sie jederzeit einstellen
können ein system dessen herren unser
geld in handumdrehen einfach stehlen
können
russland und indien indien und russland
eine seiner letzten reisen vor dem krieg
führte putin zu modi bester dinge der
inter versuchte stets den balance akt
zwischen west und ost wollte er sich
auch mit den usa nicht verscherzen es
wird aber wohl immer schwerer diese
balance zu halten
da sind einige waghalsige balance akte
zu beobachten in dieser welt aktuell
auch direkt bei uns vor der tür in
ungarn und in serbien sind am sonntag
wahlen für beide dort amtierenden
spitzenleute war wladimir putin bislang
ein vorbild und einer mit dessen
energielieferungen man die wähler
glücklich machen konnte beide
spitzenleute scheinen wenig grund zu
sehen ihre rolle und die von putin zu
überdenken
während in ungarn die opposition mit
einem zweckbündnis den machtwechsel
erreichen will sitzt serbiens starker
mann fest im sattel ausgerechnet der
krieg in der ukraine könnte dem
autoritär gesonnen putin freund die
wiederwahl sichern wolf christian
ullrich hat mehr dazu
für serbien ist präsident vujic so
unersetzbar wie ein furz werk sein
wirken und seine botschaften so
überlebenswichtig dass sie in jedem
kühlschrank gehören so suggeriert ist
dieser wahlwerbespot was viele serben
den präsidenten zu gute halten sie haben
arbeit deutsche autozulieferer zum
beispiel lassen inzwischen vermehrt in
serbien produzieren
was das wichtigste für mich ist wir
bauen fabriken fabriken und noch mehr
fabriken
für deutsche elektro autos wollte er
hier in unberührter landschaft in großem
stil lithium abbauen enteignungen und
lasche umweltauflagen sollten dabei
helfen die wut der anwohner führte im
letzten jahr zu heftigen protesten und
gab der opposition so viel rückenwind
das widget das projekt überraschend
stoppten dass umweltschutz im wahlkampf
eine rolle spielt ist neu vor allem
kämpft die liberale opposition für
rechtsstaatlichkeit und für serbiens weg
in die eu
wir müssen in die europäische union wir
müssen frieden mit unseren nachbarn
finden und in die europäische familie
denn da gehören sie hin
serbien in der eu dabei kopiert vucic
doch ausgerechnet viktor orban mithilfe
treuer oligarchen nationalismus
schmieren kampagnen und medienkontrolle
drängte er die opposition in die ecke
errichtet ein strammes machtsystem
brüssel und berlin nahmen das bis jetzt
alles lächelt in kauf europa geht es um
einfluss denn seit jahren laviert
zwischen der eu und china als investoren
und putins russland als politischen
partner beide länder verbinden kulturell
religiöse wurzeln bei öl und gas ist
serbien von russland abhängig
putin unterstützt serbische
nationalisten die im nachbarland bosnien
und herzegowina für unruhe sorgen und
kosovo nicht als unabhängig ansehen
unterwegs anhängern viele russland
freunde doch auch die angesichts des
krieges gespalten
ich bin nicht für sanktionen aber ich
unterstütze die territoriale integrität
der ukraine
serbien hat bei den vereinten nationen
putins krieg mit verurteilt deutet sich
eine neupositionierung
anmutig ich kann nicht mehr die
russische karte
ziehen so wie es bis jetzt gemacht hat
muss natürlich auch aufgrund der
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen mit dem
westen und auch der politischen
bedeutung des westens pragmatischer
werden doch coach kennt die rote linie
in seinem land
wir werden niemals der nato beitreten
drahtseilakt zwischen ost und west
sollte er die wahl gewinnen könnte vujic
danach zu ent worten gezwungen seien
die folgen des krieges gegen die ukraine
damit beginnt auch du hanna jetzt seine
nachrichtenübersicht bundeskanzlers hat
heute mit vertretern der kommunen über
die verteilung von geflüchteten aus der
ukraine beraten und darüber wer die
kosten für sie übernimmt die
bundesregierung sicherte den kommunalen
spitzenverbänden ihre unterstützung zu
diese fordern vom bund unter anderem die
zahlung einer pauschale für jeden
geflüchteten darüber gab es heute keine
einigung bund und länder wollen in einer
arbeitsgruppe ein finanzierungskonzept
erarbeiten das am kommenden donnerstag
beschlossen werden soll
die bundesanwaltschaft hat anklage gegen
einen ehemaligen reserveoffizier der
bundeswehr erhoben ihm wird vorgeworfen
für den russischen geheimdienst
spioniert zu haben
zwischen 2014 und 2020 habe der mann den
russischen nachrichtendienst mit
informationen versorgt erklärte die
bundesanwaltschaft
dabei soll es unter anderem um die
gaspipeline nord stream zwei gegangen
sein wegen seines zivilen berufs gehörte
der beschuldigte mehreren ausschüssen
der deutschen wirtschaft an die anklage
wurde bereits am 16 märz erhoben
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach hat
vor dem ende zahlreicher corona
beschränkungen in deutschland zu
weiterer vorsicht aufgerufen er rät dazu
in innenräumen weiterhin masken zu
tragen
auch wenn laut robert-koch-institut der
höhepunkt der korona welle
wahrscheinlich erreicht ist innerhalb
eines tages wurden 252
1530 neuinfektionen registriert das sind
fast 44.000 weniger als vor einer woche
304 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben
tage incidents ist ebenfalls gesunken
auf 1500
86,4
die kriegsparteien im jemen haben sich
auf eine waffenruhe von zwei monaten
geeinigt laut der vereinigten nationen
soll die feuerpause morgen beginnen in
jemen tobt seit sieben jahren einen
stellvertreterkrieg der iran unterstützt
die schiitischen houthi-rebellen
saudiarabien und andere golfstaaten die
truppen der jemenitischen regierung
vereinigten nationen schätzen dass durch
den krieg und den hunger im jemen
bereits etwa 380.000 menschen gestorben
sind
die bundesregierung will sich nicht
länger an der europäischen anti
piraterie operation atalanta am horn von
afrika beteiligen das bundeswehr mandat
werde nicht verlängert weil die
piraterie vor der küste somalias
erfolgreich reduziert wurde erklärte das
bundesverteidigungsministerium
2008 war die mission ins leben gerufen
worden um die seewege sicherer zu machen
im april läuft das mandat für den
einsatz aus
auch wenn es auf den ersten blick so
aussieht das hier ist keine große
lieferung von neuen fußbällen für die
fifa zentrale
das sind auch keine mitarbeiter der
züricher stadtreinigung es ist die
aktion eines künstlers mit ernstem
hintergrund er will hinweisen auf die
lage der menschenrechte im
austragungsland der nächsten wm kater wo
amnesty international und human rights
watch heute wieder alarm schlagen
angekommen von alledem ist hinter den
mauern bei den offiziellen des
weltfußballs nicht viel fifa chef gianni
infantino ist gerade in doha der
hauptstadt von katar und er sagt einen
satz den sie bei olympia immer am ende
der spiele sagen sicherheitshalber schon
mal bevor es überhaupt losgeht es wird
die beste wm der geschichte
béla réthy und markus haben er hatte es
zumindest nicht weit von zuhause
fifa-boss gianni infantino lebt
inzwischen in doha mehr als eine
deutliche zuwendung an den umstrittenen
gas gebe aller weltmeisterschaften als
die wm vor zwölf jahren nach katar
vergeben wurde ignorierte man alle
vorbehalte bezüglich der menschenrechte
dem arbeitsschutz oder der
diskriminierung von minderheiten jetzt
steht alles bereit nachdem angeblich
6500 menschen auf den baustellen
gestorben sind die auslosung der erste
sportliche termin der 22 in deutschland
als weltranglisten zwölfte nicht gesetzt
wird vom wm rekordspieler lothar
matthäus in die gruppe mit spanien
gezogen
zuletzt traf man sich bei einer wm 2010
in südafrika und deutschland verloren
das halbfinale mit 0 zu 1 spanien wurde
später zum einzigen mal weltmeister
so lautet diesmal der eigene anspruch
was ist denn die klare zielvorgabe der
titel die haben ja wir haben ja gesagt
dass wir dass wir weltmeister werden
wollen oder dass ich glaube alle spieler
ob das manuel neuer thomas müller sind
sind beides auch die schon ein gewisses
alter haben natürlich natürlich auch
noch mal im finale stehen wollen bei
einer weltmeisterschaft und werden alles
dafür tun auch wenn spanien gute
erinnerungen an die dfb-elf hat das
wunschlos ist es nicht
okay das ist nicht die beste mannschaft
die man bekommen konnte deutschland war
das stärkste team für mich aus topf 2
aber wie auch immer alle mannschaften
sind hier weil sie große mannschaften
haben
auch japan regelmäßig dabei der erste
deutsche gegner bei dem turnier bisher
gab es lediglich zwei
freundschaftsspiele gegen einander
zuletzt 2006 in leverkusen da gelang
schweinsteiger nach 0 2 rückstand
immerhin der ausgleich wir haben viele
japaner in der bundesliga ich sehe
dadurch ständig den deutschen fußball
und bin zuversichtlich dass wir gut
aussehen werden
offen ist noch die frage kommt costa
rica oder
neuseeland in die gruppe e das
entscheidet sich im juni in den playoffs
bei seinem ersten turnier als
cheftrainer hat hansi flick eine
schwierige gruppe erwischt abgesehen von
spanien und also die beiden trainer
schon bei der ankunft geahnt hätten dass
es zum duell kommt
drei weitere wm tickets werden noch
vergeben auch die ukrainische fußball
nationalmannschaft hat noch eine chance
sie muss dazu im juni erst gegen
schottland gewinnen und dann noch gegen
wales
und hier bei uns jetzt nochmal hanna und
zwar mit einem rekordwert den die
inflation im euroraum im märz erreicht
hat 7,5 prozent das hat es seit der
einführung des euro noch nicht gegeben
und ist auch deutlich mehr als von
experten erwartet hauptgrund für den
anstieg sind die energiekosten laut euro
statt liegt das plus im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat bei
44,7 prozent
aber auch in anderen bereichen ist das
leben deutlich teurer geworden unter
anderem bei den nahrungsmitteln und hier
dürften die preise auch noch weiter nach
oben klettern
davon geht der handelsverband
deutschland aus von zweistelligen
preissteigerungen ist die rede sina
mainitz an der frankfurter börse und
bereits am montag könnte sich das an den
supermarktkassen ganz konkret bemerkbar
machen genau dann will discounter
marktführer aldi seine preise abermals
anheben er kürzlich hat eine
preiserhöhung gegeben innerhalb der
vergangenen zwei wochen sind 180
produkte beim einzelhandelsriesen dann
teurer geworden die preise für
lebensmittel erhöhen sich ab kommenden
montag wieder um 20 bis 50 prozent bei
der butter liegt das plus bei 30 prozent
andere händler haben ebenfalls höhere
preise angekündigt laut einer umfrage
des münchner ifo instituts wollen 94
prozent der lebensmittelhändler
demnächst die preise erhöhen und damit
ihre höheren lieferanten preise an die
verbraucher weitergeben der anhaltende
krieg in der ukraine lieferengpässe
exportstopps bei agrarrohstoffen und
immer höhere energiekosten schlagen sich
nun auch auf den lebensmittelbereich
nieder mit blick auf steigende
lebensmittelpreise trafen sich heute die
agrarminister von bund und ländern es
wurde diskutiert ob brachliegende
agrarflächen zeitweise für den
nahrungsmittelanbau freigegeben werden
sollen damit könnte drohende
nahrungsmittel engpässen entgegengewirkt
werden einigen konnte man sich nicht
nächsten freitag soll nun der bundesrat
final darüber entscheiden der dax
schließt am ende der woche im plus mit
einem stand von
14.400 46 punkten leicht gestärkt geht
er damit zwar in den april doch das
minus beim dax im ersten quartal dieses
jahres die dieses jahres jahr liegt bei
fast 10 prozent nach frankfurt
der russische gaskonzern gazprom trennt
sich von seiner deutschen tochter
gazprom germania
geschäftsfelder des unternehmens sind
der handel der transport und die
speicherung von erdgas welche folgen das
für den gaslieferungen nach deutschland
haben wird ist noch unklar hinzu kommen
unsicherheiten wegen des rubel dekrets
dass der russische präsident gestern
erlassen hat laut bundesnetzagentur war
die gasversorgung in deutschland heute
allerdings stabil laut experten wären
mögliche konsequenzen ohnehin erstmal zu
merken weil die gasrechnungen
rückwirkend bezahlt werden
der erste in deutschland entwickelte und
gebaute hyper spektral satellit ist am
abend von cape canaveral aus ins all
gestartet eine trägerrakete des us
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex bringt den
erdbeobachtungssatelliten
in seine umlaufbahn in 650 kilometern
höhe soll er mindestens fünf jahre lang
neue erkenntnisse über den zustand von
seen wäldern oder anbauflächen liefern
nach schneechaos und norddeutschland
gestern hat es heute auch in der mitte
und im süden deutschlands geschneit
teilweise kam es zu ausfällen im
bahnverkehr und unfällen auf den straßen
am sonntag sollen die schneefälle
abklingen ist dahin zeigt sich der april
aber erstmal vielerorts im weißen gewand
ja kaum zu fassen es ist tatsächlich der
erste april heute das war die welt an
diesem freitag danke dass sie dabei und
wir empfehlen ihnen jetzt noch unser
heute-journal update gegen 0 uhr 15 mit
christopher bergmann vom gesamten team
in ein angenehm amt schießen
[Musik]
guten abend die schneetiefs katharina
und lotte ziehen morgen weiter nach
osten und machen ein bisschen platz für
hoch quincy aber es kommt nach wie vor
sehr kalte luft heran und so hat es ja
heute kräftig geschneit im flachland
liegen zum teil zwischen 2 und 12 cm
schnee und hier in süddeutschland ist
der regen noch gar nicht in schnee
übergegangen das wird sich jetzt aber in
der nacht ändern und auch morgen über
tag schneit es dort kräftig weiter erst
dienstagabend wird sich der schnee dann
vollständig in die mittelgebirge und an
den alpen rand zurückgezogen haben heute
nacht aber machen sie sich bitte auf
fünf bis 15 zentimeter neuschnee gefasst
auf glätte auf straßen und auf gehwegen
im osten und im nordosten ist es dagegen
trocken bei eisigem wind aus
nordwestlichen richtungen die
temperaturen sinken auf plus 2 bis minus
fünf grad und in der südhälfte bleibt es
morgen kalt bei werten um den
gefrierpunkt bilder wird es hier
norddeutschland mit fünf bis acht grad
denn dort zeigt sich häufiger die sonne
anders im saarland in rheinland pfalz in
baden-württemberg und bayern da schneit
es noch und diese schneefälle ziehen
sich im laufe des tages an den alpenrand
zurück und am sonntag wird es freundlich
und frisch bei höchsttemperaturen von
zwei bis zehn grad von nord westen kommt
regen heran und er breitet sich in der
neuen woche dann weiter aus es wird mild
am mittwoch liegen die temperaturen bei
7 bis 12 grad guten abend